[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de VIP
aujourd'hui j'ai la grande joie de
recevoir un franco-italien il s'appelle
Emmanuel et harioli et il vient de
terminé enfin il y a un petit petit peu
de temps quand même des recherches
incroyables et le résultat de ces
recherches sont notamment un roman qui
l' retrouvé on expliquera tout ça mieux
après c'est gurant le chevalier au
dragon et d'autres ouvrages dont on
parlera tout à l'heure Emmanuel et
Arioli bonjour bonjour Merci d'être
présent sur notre plateau vous avez une
histoire incroyable une actualité très
chargée et une histoire incroyable à
raconter voilà donc déjà pour vous
présenter vous êtes né en Italie vous
êtes né où je suis n à
Luino c'est c'est près de milans dans
les montagnes en Italie en lardieord ok
et vous êtes maintenant franco-italien
parce que vous êtes en France depuisu 13
ans ok donc en fait vous êtes vous êtes
médiaviste vous êtes aussi archiviste
paléographe maîre de conférence à
l'Université des haute- France et
sûrement beaucoup d'autres choses
qu'est-ce que j'oublie non non c'est
tout ben je suis voilà c'est l'essentiel
c'est l'essentiel et vous avez donc
effectuer vos études supérieures en
France alors j'ai commencé en Italie à
Pise et ensuite j'ai continué à l'École
normale supérieure de Paris à l'École
des chartes un doctor Sorbonne et
toujours dans le domaine de médiéval
tout à fait d'accord et alors on parle
de vous aujourd'hui je vous invite avec
une grande joie comme je disais tout à
l'heure parce que le livre c'estgurant
don va le chevalier au dragon voilà vous
allez le présenter ainsi que deux autres
ouvrages il y a une BD un livre sonore
et un album jeunesse au salon euh
histoire de lire à Versailles le 25-26
novembre et un documentaire vous AZ été
consacré il est euh réalisé par Marie
thry co-écrit par vous-même et Marie
thry illustration Antoine Carion il
passe sur Arté samedi 25 novembre c'est
votre weekend hein et en fait c'est un
documentaire qui va retracer toute cette
incroyable recherche dont on va parler
et euh je dis tout ça pour après comme
ça c'est dit on n'oublie plus on
n'oublie pas et c'est donc sur haré à
20h50 et c'est visible du depuis le 18
novembre jusqu'au 26 janvier voilà on a
dit tout absolument alors maintenant on
va pouvoir parler d'autres enfin
continuer alors racontez-moi vous avez
une passion pour la chevalerie pour bah
le le moyen-âge évidemment vous seriez
pas médiéviste sinon comment c'est venue
cette passion pour la chevalerie c'est
venu euh parce que je me suis intéressé
au manuscrit donc je me suis vraiment
pass quel âge ah j'étais pas enfant mais
je me suis passionné d'abord au livre et
puis un m'inscrivant à l'Univ université
j'ai commencé à travailler sur les
manuscrits et à 20 ans j'ai eu la chance
de découvrir un recueil inconnu d'un
poète italien du Moyen-Âge déjà et le
fait d'avoir fait une découverte
importante déjà avant ans m'a montré
qu'il y a encore des découvertes à
faireable et c'est pour cela qu'on
arrivé en France je suis arrivé en 2010
je suis arrivé pour faire l'école
normale supérieure et l'École des
chartes je me suis lancé à chercher des
manuscrits et voilà que je suis tombé en
2010 sur un premier manuscrit qui
contenait un texte encore inconnu de la
plus célèbre légende du Moyen-Âge la
légende duur Arthur et des Chevaliers de
la Table Ronde et donc ce texte
racontait les aventures de SEGURAN le
chevalier au dragon mais qui est que ce
SEGURAN alors segurant est un chevalier
naïf qui né d'un une île éloignée de la
cour du roi Arthur l'île non sachant et
veut devenir le meilleur chevalier de la
Table Ronde alors il traverse la mer il
traverse le royaume sauvage il se rend à
la cour du Arthur où il défie les
meilleurs chevaliers de la table ronde
lanceel y vent et cetera il vend tout le
monde mais la méchante sœur de r Arthur
Morgan fait un sortilège elle invoque un
diable qui se présente sous l'apparence
d'un dragon et seguron se retrouve
ensorcelé et obligé à poursuivre ce
monstre donc voilà l'histoire que
raconte ce manuscrit mais le manuscrit
s'arrête au milieu d'une phrase oui et
donc alors pardon il était où ce
manuscrit vous l' il était à la
Bibliothèque de l'Arsenal à Paris déjà
il était là à Paris OK et donc à partir
de ce de ce manuscrit je me suis lancé
dans une folle quête qui a duré 10 ans
pour chercher les autres morceaux parce
que vous vous êtes dit c'est pas
possible il existe forcément la suite
quelque part je me suis dit la suite
doit exister en j'imaginais pouvoir
trouver un corps des morceaux c'était
une intuition cé entièrement folle mais
en effet plusieurs mois après je
commence à trouver un premier morceau
puis deè trè donc et où alors parce
qu'en fait je crois que cette légende
elle appartient à l'Europe entière
est-ce qu'on peut dire en quelques mots
la légende du roi Arthur c'est quoi
c'est ses compagnons de la Table Ronde
tout ça la légende du roi Arthur c'est
l'histoire d'un roi le roi Arthur donc
le roi de la Grande-Bretagne qui réunit
autour de la table ronde ses meilleurs
chevaliers on connait tous linclelo
Perceval Yven et cetera et
tout alors il y a leur nombre change au
au fil des siècles en quelque sorte
parce que c'est une légende orale au
début ah au début c'est une légende
orale qui remonte peut-être déjà auss
10e siècle il y a plusieurs siècles de
transmission orale au 12e siècle il a
les premières traces écrites avec
chrétien de 3 qui forg en quelque sorte
le roman arthurien en reprenant une
légende qui est plus ancienne donc
segurant fait partie des plus anciens
romans de la Table Ronde il remamonte au
13e siècle c'est l'un des très rares
romans qu' l' en conserve c'est pour
cela que c'est une découverte majeure
c'est une découverte importante et
personne avant vous n'avait pensé pardon
qu'il y avait une suite possible
personne ne s'est rendu compte qu'il y
avait un roman à assci à ce chevalier ah
oui pourquoi parce que en fait aucun
manuscrit est complet et comme je le
disais je me suis lancé dans une quête
de 10 ans et j'ai réuni 28 manuscrits en
10 ans conservé en France en Italie en
Suisse en Belgique en Allemagne un
Grande-Bretagne aux États-Unis ah
carrément aux États-Unis ouais parce que
les manuscrits voyagent ensuite les
manusr sont ensuite rachetés et donc et
avec ces 28 manuscrits j'ai pu
reconstituer ce roman encore inconnu et
jusqu'à la fin du roman on a l'histoire
entière alors alors j'ai pu reconstituer
plusieurs versions parce que je me suis
rendu compte que c'était un BAE salaire
donc un texte qui était réécrit pendant
plusieurs siècles il faut savoir que au
Moyen-Âge souvent les textes étaient
anonymes donc les copistes les auteurs
ne laissent pas leur nom h et donc ce
texte avait réécrit pendant TR siècles
oh là làquel travail et donc et à chaque
fois ça changeait et voilà donc en fait
il fallait non pas reconstituer une
seule version mais plusieurs versions
c'est pour cela que le travail a duré 10
ans et donc dans ce texte que j'ai
traduit aux Belles Lettres vous avez
enfin le texte accessible je dirais non
pas d'une seule version mais de toutes
les aventures de ces Gurin que j'ai pu
réunir c'est pour ça qu'on parle de
romans compilés alors tout à fait on
parle d'un ensemble romanesque
c'est-à-dire qu' il y a plusieurs
versions et les copistes de l'époque
parfois ne copiaent pas les romans en
entier c'est pour cela que Marquet était
très difficile parce que parfois les
copistes prenaient un épisode par-ci un
épisode par là donc oui non c'est qu'à
leur guise exactement au Moyen-Âge on n
pas des manus écrit comme aujour'i des
livres avec des titres précis donc par
exemple c'était histoire de Merlin
histoire duur et copiaé un peu un
épisode un peu un autre et cetera donc
en fait c'est une quête extrêmement
difficile puisqu'il fallait chercher
consulter tous les manuscrits arthuiens
au monde donc des centaines et des
centaines voir des milliers de manuscrit
être sûr de tous les avoir parcourus et
alors justement un peu plusôt enfin dans
une interview vous dites je me suis j'ai
travailler à pouvoir transcrire par par
moi-même c'est cette langue alors c'est
écrit en quoi quoi c'est crré un ancien
français oh mon dieu le texte a é écrit
un Italie mais un ancien français
l'ancien
français parce que l'ancien français
était la langue romane qui était qui
avait un prestige international donc
elle était parlé pas seulement en France
mais elle était écrite aussi et lu en
Italie en grand Bretagne un peu en
Espagne et cetera d'accord donc vous
avez appris l'ancien français oui j'ai
appris le français moderne et l'ancien
français en même temps en arrivant en
Fran mon dieu mais c'est formidable du
coup vous avez pu découvrir ces ces
manuscr CR sans filtre finalement avec
absolument il faut lire les manuscrits
il faut apprendre à lire ce qui est
difficile n'est pas tellement la langue
mais l'écriture c'est écrit en écriture
gothique et parfois les manuscrits sont
tellement effacés qu'on narrive pas à
les lire à la forme des lettres la forme
des lettres a un
apprentissage pour apprendre à lire les
manuscrits anciens et après comme je le
disais certains manuscrits sont
tellement abîmés qu'on peut pas les lire
à l'œil nu alors et là on utilise par
exemple la lampe de Wood qui est l
deood la lumière ultraviolette qui
permet de lire les écritures effacées ça
les abîme pas non ça les abîme pas c'est
juste une lumière qui fait qui met en
valeur les traces métalliques de l'encre
ah mon Dieu ou alors on a l'imagériie
multispectrale qui est une technique qui
permet de prendre des photos avec des
lumières différentes des infrarouges des
ultraviolets après un ordinateur les
combine et avec cette technique je plus
lire par exemple des manuscrits brûlés
qui pas carment par exemple à Turin
n'est-ce pas oui à Turin -moi un peu à
cette grande émotion que vous avez eu
c'était le moment le plus émouvant de ma
quête puisque il y a eu un encinie
terrible à 1904 d'accord et entre 2000
et 3000 manuscrits ont brûlé ok donc
dans les réserves j'ai dû consulter des
milliers de manuscrits à limbau brûlé
calcin alors certains on n arrive pas à
les lire tellement onarrive même pas à
les ouvrir tellement ils sont des blocs
mais c'est incroyable vous trouvez dans
devant des bloc de manuscrit du 13e
siècle calciné Broué qu'est-ce qu'on
fait on s'
alors certains on peut ne peut rien
faire parce que sont des blocs on ne
peut pas les ouvrir d'autres ont été
restaurés en parti et donc on arrive à
les consulter ah et parmi ces manuscrits
j'ai trouvé des manuscrits que l'on
croyait brûl mais qui existaient encore
et dans ces manus ça qui était intact
étaai alors il était pas non le feu les
a un peu ravagé mais on arrive encore à
les lire mais les chercheurs avant mois
disaient croyait qu'ils avaient
entièrement brûlé on on savait plus où
ils étaient dans les réserves un peu le
bazar Imagineer entre 2000 et 3000
manuscrits brûlés c'est c'est beaucoup
et c'est très complexe sûr bien sûr et
donc voilà j'ai pu retrouver un épisode
clé des aventures de segurant dans ces
manuscrit brûlé pourquoi clé un épisode
clé parce que segurant enfin affronte le
monstre affronte ce dragon mais alors du
fait qu'il est ensorcelé le pauvre il
est condamné à faire ça toute sa vie il
va jamais réussir tout à fait il est
condamné à faire ça toute sa vie sauf
que il y a des copices qui ont récrit
l'histoire ah ouf pour sortir pour
sortir de cette quête sans fin donc il
ont raconé de histoire ils ont eu pitié
donc raconte par exemple qu'il arrive à
tuer le monstre ou alors il le trouve
une femme parce que cur était un
chevalier un peu atypique il n'était pas
amoureux alors que l'in avait
gagnéist lui il n'a personne il a juste
un dragon alors voilà qu'un copiste lui
a inventé une demoiselle une histoire
d'amour d'accord et en fait cette
cherche de recherche de tuer le dragon
c'est c'est son gral à lui ou pas en
quelque sorte et mais compte aussi que
seul le Graal pourra le désensourceler
alors sauf que l'épisode du Graal je ne
l'ai jamais trouvé comment ça se fait je
me demande s'il a existé ou alors s s'il
est perdu ou alors s'il n'a jamais
existé puisqueen quelque sorte on ne
pouvait pas raconter le Graal comment
raconter l'apparition du Graal peut-être
c'était ça devait rester comme ça dans
l' attente exprès OK et alors
racontez-moi quand vous décidez de faire
ces recherches qui vont donc durer dis
an qui sont très impactantes et qui vous
prennent j'imagine enfin tout votre
temps vous arrivez à travailler en même
temps parallèlement je sais pas comment
vous faites comment vous êtes perçu par
vos collègues les gens qui qui sont je
sais pas comment ça se passe ce milieu
universitaire on vous dit bravo vas-y
Emmanuel et on y croit ou alors tu es
fou comment ça se passe alors j'ai
attendu à en parler c'estàd que je fais
d'abord un master puis un doctorat et au
début je je ne parlais pas ouvertement
de ma recherche puisque je me rendais
compte que c'étaiterche et c une
découverte importante et puis je n'étais
pas sûr puisque en fait j'ai pu avoir
une vision globale seulement quand j'ai
eu les 28 manuscrits avant il me manqua
des pièces importantes donc en fait
c'était comme faire un immense puzzle
dans les pièces étaient dispersé à
travers l'Europe et lorsque j'avais
encore des pièces minquantes importantes
il était difficile d'en parler et du
coup j'ai attendu beaucoup pour faire un
premier livre universitaire et puis pour
faire trois livres universitaires en
2019 et c'est en 2019 où j'ai révélé en
quelque sorte à la communauté
ah qu'il y avait ce texte donc je fais
d'abord une édition universitaire avec
le texte ancien français c'esttait votre
tèse de doctorat tout à fait je fais ma
thèse vous avez eu des prix d'ailleurs
deux prix et pour avant comment ça
s'appelle le j'ai fais une thèse à
l'École des chartes et ensuite un
doctorat et j'ai les deux vous avez eu
plusieurs prix voilà et et donc vous
avez révélé seulement à ce moment-là oui
j'ai attendu parce que il fallait
argumenter il fallait justifier il
fallait expliquer c'est-à-dire c'était
pas juste mener cette quête de morceaux
mais c'était aussi étudier chaque
manuscrit faire une étude précise donc
j'ai attendu que tout cela soit achev
pour pour pour dévoiler l'existence vous
avez attendu 10 ans pour dévoiler votre
secret en quelque sorte incroyable on
avait encore des secrets comme ça
peut-être il y aura d'autres aventures à
venir d'autres recherches à venir ok
alors comment la communauté scientifique
enfin a réagi au début quand il y avait
pas encore les les trois volumes il y a
eu un grand étonnement et c'est
seulement quand les trois volumes sont
parus avec le texte en ancien françaisà
la communauté scientifique s'est rendu
compte voilà que c'était vrai doncil y
avait ce nouveau roman alors que on en
conserve très très peu donc c'est une
découverte oui rest combien il y en a
combien des romans de il y en a très
très peu on peu pour le 13e siècle donc
parmi les premiers romans on encre entre
7 et 10 donc c'est vraiment un texte
très très important qui nous livre aussi
un chevalier qui est très atypique qui
est le chevalier au dragon donc pas
n'importe quel chevalier alors
qu'aujourd'hui on voit des dragons
partout dans les séries dans les h c'est
voilà et à l'époque c'était un B salaire
incroyable bon écoutez c'est incroyable
voilà alors de ce livre que qui est là
donc ça c'est pour adultes au Bell
lettrre vous avez aussi CR écrit donc
une bande dessinée et un album pour
enfants et aussi un autre album un autre
livre comme ça en audio qui est lu par
Daniel mesgich on est d'accord voilà et
alors à votre avis les enfants
d'aujourd'hui comment ils perçoivent
cette cette littérature mé Val c'est
c'est c'est idio comme question mais je
je vous la pose quand même c'est c'est à
la mode ou comment comment ils
réagissent les enfants vous savez ou pas
c'est compliqué de répondre mais en tout
cas je sais que en 5e par exemple on
étudie la légende du Arthur on sait que
la légende du fait partie du patrimoine
littéraire français et aujourd'hui je
suis très ému parce que beaucoup de
personnes me me remercient me remercient
parce que il il sentent en quelque sorte
que je dévoile un patrimoine littéraire
français et c'est vrai queon connait
tous Perceval Yvin lancelo et sans doute
que à l'école au collège au lycée on
commencera aussi à étudier surant en
quelque sorte puisque j'ai commencé donc
j'ai voulu traduire le texte en français
moderne aux Belles Lettres de manière
fidèle au manuscrit mais le texte est
très lisible par les adultes mais même
pour les les plus jeunes ça reste très
lisible et puis j'ai voulu ouvrir cette
découverte à un public plus vaste donc
j'ai voulu faire une BD chez Dargo avec
le dessinateur miliano tanzil cette BD
c'est une histoire romancée qui raconte
aussi la quête du Graal je n' pas pu
trouver j'étais frustré de ne pas avoir
trouvé la quête dualenté fin donc là
j'ai inventé la fin j'ai inventé en tout
cas une histoire complète avec aussi
cette quête du Graal en m'inspirant de
plein de sources du Moyen-Âge de plein
de légendes différentes et après j'ai
voulu aussi faire ce livre pour enfants
toujours avec le dessinateur Émilien
notanzilo et alcos un autre dessinateur
au Seuil jeunesse et c'est un texte qui
a la particularité de raconter à la fois
ma quête à travers l'Europe et puis
l'histoire de segurant d'accord c'est
Liv a parallèle en fait c'est tressé et
donc à chaque comme dans le film haré à
chaque fois que je découvre un fragment
il y a l'histoire du fragment in
question donc et c'est un vraiment un
livre qui est destiné aux enfants entre
6 et 12 ans qui veut donner envie
d'aimer l'histoire en génal d'aimer la
recherche d'aimer l'histoire et qui met
en scène vraiment et ça c'est je pense
que c'est assez nouveau comment se passe
la recherche en histoire donc comment la
recherche sur les manuscrits comment
chercheur historien leur montrer qu'elle
est pas forcment pour les mais en tout
cas sa pas mais montrer ce métier voilà
montrer ce métier montrer ce métier
comment ça marche de manière très simple
très accessible mais mon expliquer ce
que ce que c'est le moyen-âge ce qui est
un manuscrit ce qui est un chercheur
médiaviste tout ça ouais c'est extra ok
donc ça vous allez le présenter donc
présenteer tous ces livres mais vous
êtes du côté enfant ou du côté adulte au
salon au belles lettres donc je serai du
côté adulte mais je présente
allé faire des interventions dans les
écoles déjà ou pas encore euh pas encore
pas encore mais j'ai hâte justement et
et en tout cas j'ai rencontré plusieurs
enfants qui étaient à des conférences et
et c'est très émouvant comment il il s
s'approprie de cette histoire et comment
il rentre dans cette histoire du du
chercheur et parce qu'il y a aussi dans
cette dans ce livre il y a aussi un un
protagoniste qui est un enfant ah ou
c'est pour c'est pour pour qu'il se il
se projette plus d' et en fait je vois
que voilà ils aim aime beaucoup
l'histoire et et je suis ravi parce que
il découvre comme ça un métier qu'il
découvrerit pasutement voilà extra OK et
al comment on vit comme ça quand on a
consacré 10 ans à ces recherches et à ce
secret et et là aujourd'hui vous avez un
vide incroyable ou vous êtes sur un
autre projet ce n'est pas encore un vide
incroyable puisque il y a en parler
encore train de Vire le livre là les
livres sont sortis en France mais ils
vont sortir aussi en Italie en Espagne
en Allemagne le terre donc en fait voilà
parler partout donc je resitue à l' vous
allez pas vous séparer de façon trop
brutale de de votre bébé oui je Resit à
l'Europe ce qui a été un bestsellerire
au 13e siècle donc voà vous allez faire
aller sur les routes européennes et
juste pour terminer le une dernière
chose j'ai vu que vous étiez aussi
acteur oui et alors en parallèle à votre
métier d'historien et vous avez joué
donc le film de Bruno du Mont France le
film France de Bruno du monont voilà
vous êtes un un l'amant de l'amant de la
protagoniste incarné par lesd voà oui et
ça c'était votre premier rôle j'avais
joué dans plusieurs courtmétrage mais
c'était le premier long métrage dans
lequel je jouais c'était une expérience
extraordinaire parce que vous avez fait
pris des cours de d'art dramatique
ouiatoire aussi oui oui donc bientôt
vous allez chanter euh peut-être pas
mais dans le film de France de Bruno
Dion je chante aussi et vous avez aussi
travaillé avec ovidi oui vous avez fait
quoi j'apprécie beaucoup le travail
d'ovidi donc j'ai fait un courtmétrage
avec elle le titre est d'autres chats à
foueté et puis je joue dans la nouvelle
saison la saison 2 des de la série des
gens bien ordinaire sur Canal Plus qui
vient de
recevoir hier un Emy Award donc c'est
une le deè SC bon ben génial et vous
êtes dedans oui absolument donc on vous
retrouve ben écoutez pour ceux qui
veulent au salon sur Arté et à très
bientôt pour un nouveau scoop une
nouvelle découverte avec plaisir ok à
bientôt merci beaucoup au revoir au
revoir à tous merci de nous avoir
[Musique]
suivi